J'ai passé les dernières années
à essayer de résoudre deux énigmes :
pourquoi la productivité est si décevante
dans toutes les entreprises où j'ai travaillé ?
J'ai travaillé avec plus de 500 entreprises.
Malgré tous les progrès technologiques --
ordinateurs, informatique, communications, télécommunications,
et Internet.
La deuxième énigme est :
pourquoi y a-t-il si peu d'implication au travail ?
Pourquoi les gens se sentent tellement malheureux,
voire vivement désengagés ?
Ils désengagent leurs collègues.
Ils agissent contre l'intérêt de leur entreprise.
Malgré tous les événements qui encouragent le sentiment d'appartenance,
les fêtes, les initiatives des gens,
les programmes de développement du leadership
pour former les directeurs à mieux motiver leurs équipes.
Au début, je pensais qu'on était face
au dilemme de la poule et de l'œuf :
parce que moins engagés, les gens sont moins productifs
ou vice versa, puisqu'ils sont moins productifs,
mis sous plus de pression, ils sont moins engagés.
Cependant, durant nos analyses
on s'est rendu compte d'une cause commune
des deux problèmes, qui concerne, en fait, les piliers de base du management.
La façon dont nous nous organisons est fondée sur deux piliers.
Un dur, qui concerne la structure, les processus, les systèmes.
Un flexible qui concerne les sentiments, les relations,
les caractères et les personnalités.
Chaque fois qu'une entreprise
se réorganise, se restructure, se redéfinit,
ou passe par un programme de transformation culturelle,
elle choisit ces deux piliers.
Aujourd'hui, nous essayons de les affiner et de les combiner.
Le vrai problème est --
c'est la réponse aux deux énigmes --
que ces piliers sont dépassés.
Tout ce que vous lisez dans les livres de management est basé
soit sur l'un ou l'autre ou les deux.
Ils sont dépassés.
Comment fonctionnent-ils lorsque vous essayez
de les utiliser contre la nouvelle complexité des entreprises ?
L'approche dure est celle que vous appliquez à partir de la stratégie,
les exigences, les structures, les processus, les systèmes, les ICP,
les tableaux de bord prospectifs, les comités, les sièges,
Appelez ça comme vous voulez.
J'ai oublié tous les indicateurs, les primes, les comités,
le suivi de marché, les interfaces.
Ce qui se passe réellement,
on se retrouve avec plus de complexité, la nouvelle complexité de l'entreprise.
Nous avons besoin de qualité, de coût, de fiabilité, de vitesse.
Chaque fois qu'il y a une nouvelle exigence,
nous utilisons la même approche.
Nous créons des systèmes de traitement avec une structure spécifique,
pour faire face à la nouvelle complexité de l'entreprise.
Cette approche dure crée juste plus de complexité
dans l'organisation.
Prenons un exemple.
Dans une entreprise d'automobile, la division d'ingénierie
est une matrice à cinq dimensions.
Si vous ouvrez n'importe quelle cellule de la matrice,
vous allez trouver une autre matrice avec 20 dimensions.
Vous avez M. Bruit, M. Consommation d'essence,
M. Anticollision.
Pour toute nouvelle exigence,
vous avez une fonction spécifique
responsable de l'alignement des ingénieurs avec
la nouvelle exigence.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand il y a une nouvelle exigence ?
Il y a quelques années, une nouvelle exigence
est apparue sur le marché :
la durée de la période de garantie.
C'était la réparation, rendre les voitures faciles à réparer.
Autrement dit, quand vous ramenez la voiture
au garage pour réparer l'éclairage,
si vous devez retirer le moteur
pour accéder aux phares,
la voiture devra rester une semaine dans le garage
au lieu de deux heures, le budget de garantie va exploser.
Quelle est la solution en utilisant l'approche dure ?
Si la réparation est la nouvelle exigence,
la solution est de créer une nouvelle fonction,
M. Réparation.
M. Réparation crée le processus de la réparation.
Avec une carte de performance et une métrique de la réparation
et finalement une incitation à la réparation.
Il est au top des 25 autres ICP.
Quel pourcentage de ces gens a une rémunération variable ?
20% au plus, divisé par 26 ICP,
la réparation fait une différence de 0,8%.
Quelle différence ça a fait dans leurs actions,
leurs choix pour simplifier ? Zéro.
Mais qu'arrive-t-il à l'impact zéro ? M. Réparation, processus,
carte de performance, l'évaluation,
la coordination avec les 25 autres coordinateurs
d'avoir un impact zéro.
Face à la nouvelle complexité de l'entreprise,
la seule solution est de ne pas dessiner des tableaux
avec des rapports managériaux.
Il s'agit plus précisément de l'interaction.
Comment les parties vont travailler ensemble ?
Les connexions, les interactions, les synapses.
Ce n'est pas le squelette des tableaux, c'est le système nerveux
de l'adaptabilité et l'intelligence.
Vous pourriez l'appeler la coopération,
chaque fois que les gens coopèrent,
ils utilisent moins de ressources. Dans tous les domaines.
La question de la réparation
est un problème de coopération.
Lorsque vous concevez des voitures, s'il vous plaît, prenez en compte
les besoins de ceux qui vont réparer les voitures dans les garages.
Sans coopération, nous avons besoin de plus de temps,
plus d'équipements, plus de systèmes et plus d'équipes.
Quand les achats, les approvisionnements, la fabrication
ne coopèrent pas nous avons besoin de plus de stock,
plus d'inventaires plus de capitaux.
Qui va payer pour cela ?
Les actionnaires ? Les clients ?
Non, ils vont refuser.
Alors, il nous reste qui ? Les employés,
qui doivent compenser par leurs efforts individuels
le manque de coopération.
Le stress, le surmenage, ils sont débordés, les accidents.
Pas étonnant qu'ils se désinvestissent !
Comment l’approche dure et l'approche flexible
essayent-elles de favoriser la coopération ?
L'approche dure : dans les banques, quand il y a un problème
de coopération entre le back office et le front office,
Alors quelle est la solution ?
Ils inventent le suivi de marché.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe un an plus tard ?
Au lieu d'un problème, maintenant, j'en ai deux.
Entre le back office et le suivi de marché et entre ce dernier et le front office.
En plus, je dois payer le suivi de marché.
L'approche dure n'est pas en mesure de favoriser la coopération.
Elle ajoute seulement de nouveaux tableaux,
de nouveaux os au squelette.
Alors que dans l'approche flexible :
pour faire coopérer les gens, nous devons leur apprendre à s'aimer.
Améliorer les sentiments interpersonnels,
plus les gens s'aiment, plus ils vont coopérer.
C'est totalement faux.
Il est même contre-productif.
Par exemple, à la maison, j'ai deux téléviseurs. Pourquoi ?
Pour ne pas avoir à coopérer avec ma femme.
(Rires)
Pour ne pas avoir à imposer des compromis à ma femme.
Pourquoi j'essaie de ne pas imposer des compromis à ma femme ?
Justement parce que je l'aime.
Si je n'aimais pas ma femme, un téléviseur serait suffisant :
tu vas regarder mon équipe de foot préférée,
si tu n'es pas heureuse, prend un livre ou la porte. (Rires)
Plus nous nous aimons les uns les autres,
plus nous évitons la vraie coopération
qui grèverait nos relations en imposant des compromis difficiles.
C'est parti pour un deuxième téléviseur ou nous remontons
la décision vers la hiérarchie pour l'arbitrage.
Et sans aucun doute, ces approches sont obsolètes.
Pour faire face à la complexité, pour améliorer le système nerveux,
nous avons créé l'approche de la simplicité intelligente
basée sur des règles simples.
La règle simple numéro un :
Comprendre ce que les autres font.
Quel est leur vrai travail ?
Nous devons aller au-delà des boîtes
des descriptions d'emploi, au-delà de la surface du contenant,
pour comprendre le contenu réel.
Moi, concepteur, si je mets un fil ici,
je sais que ça signifie que nous devrons
enlever le moteur pour accéder aux phares.
Deuxièmement, vous devez renforce les intégrateurs.
Les intégrateurs ne sont pas du suivi de marché, ce sont des gestionnaires
existants que vous renforcez
afin qu'ils aient le pouvoir et l'intérêt
de pousser les autres à coopérer.
Comment pouvez-vous rendre vos gestionnaires comme les intégrateurs ?
En supprimant les couches.
Quand il y en a trop, les gens sont trop loin de l'action,
ils ont donc besoin du ICP, les métriques,
de mauvais indicateurs de la réalité.
Ils ne comprennent pas la réalité
et ils augmentent de la complication des métriques et ICP.
En supprimant les règles, plus on est grand,
plus nous avons besoin des intégrateurs,
nous devons donc avoir moins de règles,
pour donner le pouvoir discrétionnaire aux gestionnaires.
Nous faisons le contraire -- plus on est grand, plus on crée de règles.
Nous nous retrouvons à la fin avec une encyclopédie de règles.
Vous devez augmenter la quantité d'énergie pour responsabiliser tout le monde
à utiliser leur jugement, leur intelligence.
Vous devez donner plus de cartes à ces gens
afin qu'ils aient la masse critique de cartes
pour prendre le risque de coopérer,
de sortir de l'isolement.
Sinon, ils vont se retirer et se désengager.
Ces règles viennent de la théorie des jeux
et la sociologie des organisations.
Vous pouvez augmenter l'ombre de l'avenir.
Créer des boucles de rétroaction qui exposent les gens
aux conséquences de leurs actes.
C'est ce que les constructeurs automobiles ont fait
voyant que M. Réparation n'a eu aucune incidence.
Ils ont dit aux ingénieurs d'études :
Désormais, en trois ans, lors du lancement de la nouvelle voiture,
vous serez transférés au réseau du service après-vente,
vous serez responsable du budget de la garantie,
et si le budget de la garantie vient à exploser,
vous allez la prendre en plein le visage. (Rires)
Beaucoup plus puissant que 0,8% de la rémunération variable.
Vous devez également augmenter la réciprocité,
en retirant les tampons qui nous rendent autosuffisants.
En le faisant,
nous serons liés et obligés de coopérer.
Enlever le deuxième téléviseur.
Il y en a beaucoup au travail qui n'a aucune valeur ajoutée,
ils fournissent juste une autosuffisance dysfonctionnelle.
Vous devez récompenser ceux qui coopèrent
et blâmer ceux qui ne coopèrent pas.
Le directeur général du groupe Lego,
Jorgen Vig Knudstorp, a une excellente façon de l'utiliser.
Il dit, on ne blâme pas pour l'échec,
mais pour ne pas avoir aidé ou demandé de l'aide.
Ça change tout.
Soudain, il devient dans mon intérêt d'être transparent
quant à mes vraies faiblesses, mes vraies prévisions,
car je sais que je ne vais pas être blâmé si j'échoue,
mais plutôt si je n'ai pas aidé ou demandé de l'aide.
Cela a beaucoup de conséquences, lorsque vous le faites,
sur la conception organisationnelle.
Vous arrêtez de dessiner les tableaux, les lignes pointillées ou complets ;
vous regardez leur interaction.
Il influence beaucoup les politiques financières
que nous utilisons.
Sur les pratiques de gestion des ressources humaines.
En le faisant, vous pouvez gérer la complexité,
la nouvelle complexité de l'entreprise, sans devenir compliqué.
Vous créez plus de valeur à moindre coût.
Vous améliorez en même temps la performance et la satisfaction au travail
parce que vous avez déraciné la cause commune
qui les a empêchés de se développer.
La complexité est votre bataille, à vous les chefs d'entreprise.
Car la vraie bataille n'est pas contre les concurrents.
C'est faux et très abstrait.
Quand avons-nous rencontré des concurrents pour les combattre ?
La vraie bataille est contre nous-mêmes,
contre notre bureaucratie, notre complexité.
Vous seul pouvez combattre, vous pouvez le faire.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)